a-rod wants you to know he left his dad
bod in 2020.
every day you should wake up with you
know let's go follow your dreams the 45
year old former baseball pro flaunts his
recent body transformation on
instagram posting this before and after
photo on wednesday
showing off the results of his hard work
on the left
a-rod in december 2020 and on the right
a-rod in april 2021. he writes in the
caption quote
left the dad bod in 2020. well that's a
good thing
the entrepreneur also sheds light on how
he went about leading a healthier
lifestyle
explaining that 2021 is the year he felt
determined
to stick with his health and fitness
goals quote i've been consistent with my
workouts and
finally put down the chips and if you
need further proof
just check out a-rod's chiseled arm that
he showed off while getting his covet 19
vaccine
talk about looking and feeling good i
tried
but we know fitness has always been
hugely important to the former pro
athlete in 2019 he took viewers inside
his intense workout routine
alongside then-fiance jennifer lopez
weights resistance training cardio
and of course a little dancing it's not
easy to win
i need to do a champion champions
don't start in the boardroom they start
away from let's go a-rod's fit physique
isn't the only recent change in his life
he's also newly single after splitting
from jlo
whom he was engaged to for two years and
they dated for four
the pair released a joint statement to
et earlier this month
explaining that they realized they're
better off as friends
and will remain so as they continue
working together on shared businesses
and
projects jennifer's one of the most
brilliant business minds i've ever met
she's the hardest working lady and how's
this for friendly exes
the pair dined together last week at
hotel bel air in los angeles
a source tells et that they arrived and
left separately adding that the dinner
did not appear to be a romantic
situation
together apart or just friends
we love to see a-rod keeping his health
and wellness a top priority
you